if you are a man you have a pair of
egg-shaped glands called testicles
enclosed in your scrotum which is a
pouch that hangs behind your penis your
testicles produce sperm cells and make
the hormone testosterone inside each
testicle are coiled tubes called
seminiferous tubules where your body
creates immature sperm cells also known
as germ cells or spermatogonia through a
series of stages called spermatogenesis
spermatogonia develop into mature sperm
testicular cancer is a disease of
abnormal cell growth in one or both of
your testicles
it usually begins in your germ cells
where genetic damage or changes called
mutations cause the cells to grow
uncontrollably the cancerous germ cells
clump together to form a tumor which
continues to grow in most cases these
mutations occur in your germ cells and
are called germ cell tumors
doctors classified germ cell tumors as
non seminoma or seminoma or based on the
appearance of the cells under a
microscope
non seminoma tests to murrs are usually
more aggressive they grow and spread
quickly while seminoma tests tumors tend
to progress at a slower rate
symptoms of testicular cancer may
include a painless mass on your testicle
or testicular pain or swelling
if you have testicular cancer your
doctor may recommend surgery
chemotherapy radiation therapy or a
combination of treatments based on the
type and stage of the tumor
your treatment will begin with removal
of the cancerous testicle through a
radical inguinal orchiectomy for this
procedure your surgeon will make an
incision in your lower abdomen then your
surgeon will remove your testicle from
your scrotum your surgeon will close the
incision with sutures or surgical
staples
next your pathologist will analyze the
testicle to determine which type of
cancer you have and to plan further
treatment
if you have enlarged abdominal lymph
nodes or if samples of your blood
indicate the presence of cancer
following your orchiectomy surgery your
doctor may recommend chemotherapy
chemotherapy uses drugs to stop cancer
from progressing by killing the cancer
cells that may have spread through your
lymph nodes to other parts of your body
if your tumor contains the more
aggressive non seminoma cells your
surgeon may perform a retroperitoneal
lymph node dissection
after you receive chemotherapy
during this procedure your surgeon will
insert laparoscopic tools through small
incisions in your abdomen then your
surgeon will remove your abdominal lymph
nodes including any cancer cells that
may have spread to them
if you have a seminoma 'test tumour your
doctor may recommend radiation therapy
or radiotherapy which uses high-energy
x-rays to kill cancer cells only in the
treatment area
during this procedure your doctor will
direct external beam radiation therapy
at your retroperitoneal abdominal lymph
nodes
the radiation beam will kill any cancer
cells that may have spread there